It was just layers of information that arrived
seemingly effortlessly.
When I was very little, she told me funny little tales about the watchman's dog
or about what- how they had to cope with going to the toilet when they were in hiding.
And they didn't actually talk about
the much more difficult elements of the story until later,
but they were drip fed and bed,
and because they spoke about it among themselves a lot.
It also wasn't about me being told it was just about listening
to the talk around the table,
because they spoke about it all the time,
which is very rare in survivors' families.
In a way, it was the most exciting thing that ever happened to them.
And so it was such a huge thing in their life
They talked about the biggest thing that my mom was 17,
such a formative experience.
and it was - it formulated the way they saw the world -
It defined them as people in different ways.
It was always the underpinning- narrative
of everything that happened, subsequently.
They always said that they saw not only the worst of humanity,
but also the best of humanity.
The fact that they were saved.
They were saved by the people that supported them.
A life affirming experience in the midst of all this horror,
which is crazy,
but there was that real balance of extremes that made it
a really vital background, you know,
and you've got that absolute extremes of horror
and extremes of somebody who is prepared to risk-
as my mother always would say,
not only his life, but the life of this entire family.
I needed a project and I just I said to my Mum:
Why don't we draw the box?
Because she'd always talked about the box.
They both always talked about the box.
And when I was little, I had a very clear idea of the box,
because she would describe it to me, and she would say,
my me and your father would lie this way,
and your grandma would lie this way.
We could only come out at night.
And I had a toy box in my room,
so in my head, that was this. That was the box.
The lid would open at night.
And I think there was probably a kids program
where toys came out of a box at night.
That was my image of the box for many, many years.
And I was in my 20s, when I went to Amsterdam for the first time,
went to the Anne Frank House.
Oh, my God, this is what hiding place is like.
How ridiculous. All those years I've been thinking of this box
We started to talk about and I said: Why don't we draw it?
So I started to do little sketches,
and she'd look at them and go:  'I don't know'
You know, it's a piece of paper, it was an object.
So then I started to make little models years in theater.
So I started sticking things together and balsa wood models,
and I'd bring them to Huddersfield to show her,
and she'd go 'a bit smaller that way', or 'the bed was a bit higher',
and I'd go and remake it.
She still go 'No, I don't know.' And then eventually I said:
'Well, look, why don't- it's only, you know, it's only six foot square.
Why don't I make a rough layout of it?
So I got some two by one,
and I screwed it together into a rough frame,
and I covered it with paper. I said, come and have a look.
She walked into this space, and she looked at it and said:
'Oh, the door's on the wrong side.'
You've seen 25 drawings and five models.
How come you're only just realizing?
It was real learning moment of
actuallythe real thing is completely different.
And although I can work in drawings and I can think in models,
not everyone can. So I built the real thing to scale.
I showed it as my end of year piece.
And she came to the opening, and she said: It's very good.
She said, 'but still a little bit t oo big',
because my head, you know, you just, you go,
it must have been. And then she said, Five foot, five,
took six inches off it. Rebuilt it, installed it in the museum,
and she came and looked at it, and she said: Now it's perfect.
I remembered the 'Night of the Ghetto'
the book that my dad had written.
And went back to that and thought
What did he write about the hiding place?
And how it was situated?
And so I went and read his description,
astonished to find that his dimensions were different.
They were smaller still.
So that was sort of the start of it
was that notion that memory was not fixed.
So I then built his version of the box,
her version of the box,
and my imagined version of the box
For her the most difficult thing
and the thing that she never really dealt with, actually, I think
the one thing that was profoundly difficult was her father's death.
When they came out of the ghetto,
she wasn't sure if she wanted to leave England,
because her little brother- leave for England
because her little brother was in Kaunas
But the one deciding factor was that she said
she would have found it very difficult to stay in Lithuania
and to walk down the streets and to never know
if the man she was passing was the man
that had beaten her father to death.
He was arrested the day after the German invasion,
and he was beaten to death, along with 50 to 60 other Jews
by Lithuanians with clubs in the yard of a garage
on the Wednesday two days later.
And she didn't find out about it till after the war,
and then in the 50s, a German newspaper published photographs
of the event, because there'd been Wehrmacht officers present
who had taken photographs,
and these photographs were printed in a German newspaper.
And she got copies of those photographs,
and she put them in the back of the family album.
She was obsessed by photographs.
She had albums upon albums of photographs,
and in one of those albums, on the back two pages
were these two photographs of groups of men
having been clubbed to death
and the man standing over them still with the clubs.
And they were in our family albums.
I'd always known they were there,
so I grew up seeing them in the back of the albums.
When I was doing history at school,
we were asked to bring in something from home about the war.
So I snuck into my mum's bedroom and I took
from the back of the photo album these two photographs
without telling her. And the reason I didn't tell her was not
for a moment that I thought she would mind me taking them.
It was because I was terrified that I knew be in such trouble
that I had left it till the morning of the lesson to do my homework,
so I didn't dare tell her, and if I'd asked her,
maybe we would have had a discussion about how to navigate it.
But we didn't. I just grabbed them and went to school.
And because I'd seen them all my life,
and because I'd known this story all my life,
I had no idea the impact of it.
And everybody else had brought in, you know,
I think somebody might have brought in a medal,
and somebody might have brought in a box of matches,
and I brought in a couple of photographs
of my grandfather being clubbed to death,
which was quite a, quite an extraordinary thing to do on reflection.
But I did it very casually, and I think my history teacher loved me.
I think it was the best history lesson she ever gave,
and she didn't have to do anything.
How do you tell stories that are accessible and engaging
about something that's so terrible?
I was born on the 28th of October,
which is the anniversary of what was called
the big action in the Kaunas ghetto.
The ghetto was closed at the end of August,
and on the 28th of October,
a decree was issued well prior to the 28th of October,
that all the inhabitants of the ghetto that
at that time were just short of 30,000
should gather in the square of the Democrats at 6am.
Anyone remaining in their houses was going to be killed.
Going to be killed, so that everyone had to go.
And the ghetto was divided into two.
People were sent to the left or to the right,
and those sent to the left were murdered that that next day,
and that was just short of 10,000
So this was such a huge event in everyone's experience at the ghetto.
You speak to any survivor of the Kaunas ghetto,
and they will talk in almost the same language about that day.
It's extraordinary.
So for my mum, it was really important that I was born on that day.
Because it meant that something good happened on a day
that something so terrible had happened.
For me, that's, that's one of the most important things
about that heritage that I have
is that sense of how close that line is,
between survival and death,
between success and fate.
You know, all those lines, how thin lines are generally.
And I think that's something that
I feel privileged to have grown up with,
because it makes life more when death is so close.
You know, I don't just want to share the horrors of this story.
I want to share what my parents took from it, which is
how it can feed us,
and how we can gain and grow
and take something from them,
It's vital, because we're going to stop horrible things happening,
but we might be able to learn how to navigate them.